House Intelligence chairman the
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez and House
Oversight Committee chairman trey Gowdy
they actually went to the Department of
Justice to view documents they have been
requesting and that were under subpoena
for months but sources tell Fox News
that Nunez and Gowdy were only briefed
about the documents that another meeting
is scheduled next week for them to
actually see it but the best way to get
the answer is to talk to somebody was in
that meeting that's chairman trey Gowdy
and from the House Judiciary Committee
Congressman John Radcliffe of Texas both
are former federal prosecutors both have
been in the system both have been
through this process and I thank you
gentlemen for joining us on this
beautiful Friday night chairman Gowdy
did you get a lot of lip service did you
actually get to read the documents and
what did they tell you you know Jason it
was a really productive meeting
yesterday I think every question I asked
the bureau and and in the department now
understand they're relevant the material
there they're specific they're pointed
and there's a reason that Congress wants
to know the answers to these questions
so it was a really constructive I know
that is not good news from the media
standpoint that we had a boring
constructive meeting yesterday but
that's exactly what it was and it was so
constructed that we've agreed to meet
next week so you asked if we saw
something I can learn with my ears and I
can learn with my eyes and yesterday was
important because I got to hear the
department's perspective but also got to
ask questions you're right
Johnny and our prosecutors I know the
questions to ask in an investigation
like this and I need witnesses there
that can answer them yesterday was
really productive well when do you
actually get to see them well you know
let me say this I've worked in all three
branches of government and there is
tension there's intentional tension put
between the branches there are lots of
things that happen in the judicial
branch that members of Congress can't
see there are things that happen the
executive branch the members of Congress
can't see and they're things we do Jason
as you recall in Congress that we don't
let anybody else see so that tension
we've got to work through I learned
information this week I still would like
to see the documents I think they've
taken that request under advisement and
I think we're getting farther taking
this approach
eyeball to eyeball as opposed to
exchanging letters and seeing who can
leak them the quickest and that is not
constructive
what is constructive is to have a
conversation and I think we're making
progress towards accessing the documents
well it's a shame that Nunez had to you
know issue a subpoena and threaten
contempt and the Southern gentleman and
trey gowdy is coming out but i'm glad
you're making incremental progress step
by head stuff I want to I want to go to
John Ratcliffe who's I want to get your
perspective on on James Comey because
he's fresh off a book tour he said an
awful lot of things and we've learned a
lot more about director Comey I mean
this is he made the situation better or
worse for himself after this book tour
the things that we've learned about his
actions while he was the FBI director
well Jason could be with you I think one
of the things that has come out of Jim
Comey's interviews on his book tour and
the release of his secret memos is it's
ironic to me that he's the one that
created the allegation of obstruction of
justice against Donald Trump and now
he's the same person who has effectively
torpedoed the ability of the Special
Counsel to ever prove obstruction and I
say that because the 15 pages of secret
memos never mention obstruction of
justice a single time and in fact one of
the memos does exactly the opposite it
says that it's an admission by the
former director that President Trump
asked him to fully investigate whether
or not anyone with the Trump campaign
was colluding with the Russians is why
Trey and I have both referred to that
memo as defense Exhibit A and any
charges that would be brought against
Donald Trump but I think he's also hurt
the Muller case and the ability to prove
that you can't build a case around the
star witness who has damaged his own
credibility and hurt his own reputation
as I think Jim Comey has done over the
last few weeks on this book tour well do
you think does he have any legal
jeopardy himself director Comey well I
think the best answer to that Jason will
come with the release of the Inspector
General report you know we all
anticipate that that will happen shortly
we also know that the Inspector General
Michael Horowitz is someone who's proven
himself to be a fair umpire
who calls balls and strikes fairly and
was where appropriate willing to make a
criminal referral of the deputy FBI
director I will tell you not having seen
the report I'll be surprised if the
Inspector General doesn't find
misconduct by former director Comey I
think he'll find that he violated his
employment agreement made unauthorized
disclosures of FBI documents and whether
they're classified or not those are
improper leaks and I think he'll find
that he made demonstrably false
statements is I think has been
highlighted by some of the congressional
transcripts that have been related
recently as they conflict with some of
the public interviews that he's been
given so I'm confident that if it's
appropriate Michael Horowitz will make
that recommendation chairman Gowdy when
do we expect to see this report we keeps
getting delayed a little bit you're
gonna hold I believe the first hearing
and what do you expect out of this do
you think there will it be any criminal
referrals coming from this I don't know
about the criminal referrals you know I
members of Congress I've steadfastly
tried to avoid accusing people of
committing crimes that was my old job I
don't know enough to do it I know this
all three of us have tremendous
confidence in Michael Horowitz the
Inspector General he's a former federal
prosecutor he's a straight arrow eight
beat just the very fact centric I think
the reason it's taking longer Jason than
he anticipated is he's finding more
information so what I would tell my my
colleagues in the house is giving the
time and the independence and the
resources to do everything he needs to
do I know that we wanted it in February
in March and and that's human nature to
want it quicker but I want it to be
complete and I wanted to be fulsome and
I want the American people to have
confidence and what Horowitz has done
and if he could represent that he's
accessed every document and every
witness I mean stop and think he found
the page struck text then he found the
fact that some of them had been deleted
and then through his help they were
reconstructed so I'm as impatient as
everyone else I just I know this I want
Horowitz to present a fulsome picture
when he comes and if that means waiting
another couple of weeks then so be it
do you have a date do we have a date
when you're actually going to have
hearing we've set one and then we moved
it and you remember how that used to be
we are shooting for the first week of
June but I will say with this caveat and
you know Harlow is Jason he's not giving
me any updates on his investigation nor
should he nor what I asked I am simply
saying we'd like to schedule the hearing
and I'll pick a date and he'll tell me
whether or not he thinks he's gonna meet
that target date or not but I have no
inside information and I'm not supposed
to real quickly congressman Ratcliffe in
like 10 seconds director Muller how long
do you think this continues to go on and
how would it impact the 2018 election or
will he wrap this thing up well I think
he has to be very careful I don't know I
don't want to put a specific date on it
but I I think that Bob Muller needs to
be careful not to make the same mistake
that both Republicans and Democrats
critics criticized Jim Comey for which
was allowing an investigation to impact
an election which I think if Republicans
and Democrats agreed and it happened in
2016
gentlemen it's it's good to be on the
air with you as an honor a privilege to
serve with you in the Congress and I
thank you for joining us tonight